we have this diagram here party
divisions of the United States Congress
and what this helps us visualize is
which parties controlled the various
houses of Congress as well as which
party was in control of the White House
so for example during Lyndon Johnson's
administration he was a Democrat that's
why it is colored it in blue and then we
see in this light blue color the Senate
leaned towards the Democrats and the
house in this dark blue color leaned
towards the Democrats as well but then
when you get to Richard Nixon you have
one party the Republicans controlling
the White House while the other party
the Democrats controlled Congress and so
this situation right over here is known
as a divided divided government and as
we look down this diagram we see that it
is not that unusual Gerald Ford had a
divided government Ronald Reagan had a
somewhat divided government where the
house significantly leaned towards the
Democrats although the Senate started to
lean a little bit towards the
Republicans but then if we go further
down in time we see more and more
divided governments so if we go all the
way down to at least the present when
this video was created we see that
George HW Bush faced a divided
government he was a Republican you had
the House and the Senate leaned towards
the Democrats Bill Clinton at the
beginning it wasn't divided but most of
his administration he had a divided
government George W Bush had a divided
government near the end of his
administration and Obama dealt with a
divided government during the second
half of his first term and his second
term one question is why does it matter
if you have a divided government like we
had let's say in this time period right
over here well one negative of it that
some people will often cite is that you
might have some form of extreme
partisanship and partisanship is just a
word that says that the various
political actors will think more about
their party in their political ideology
than maybe what is in their best
interest for the people or they would
try to do things
in order to get political points as
opposed to just good governance and one
byproduct of partisanship would be a
phenomenon known as gridlock you might
have heard the word gridlock before when
it comes to traffic gridlock is when
there's just so much traffic that
nothing is moving that people can't just
can't get around and it essentially
means the same thing in a political
context if you have a divided government
and one party isn't allowing if
everything that the Congress passes the
president vetoes or if everything that
the president wants to do the Congress
doesn't want to work along with them
well then nothing might happen and you
might get to a gridlock situation and
for a lot of people that's a significant
negative but there are some viewpoints
that maybe a divided government isn't as
bad as it sometimes looks some people
would argue that you don't want the
government always doing exactly what
they want when you have a non divided
government in fact if you have a divided
government they'll only do things that
really really really really matter where
there is more of a broad consensus
there's also this view from Mitch
McConnell who's the current leader of
the US Senate that it's actually easier
to get things done during a divided
government this is a part of an article
from the New York Times written in 2011
it says divided government is the
perfect time to do big things the
perfect time mr. McConnell said in a
recent session with New York Times
reporters and editors he cited three
fairly recent examples of major
legislative bargains that were struck
with one party in the White House and
another running things on Capitol Hill
the 1983 overhaul of Social Security
negotiated between President Ronald
Reagan and speaker Tip O'Neill Ronald
Reagan was of course Republican and
Speaker of the House Tip O'Neill was a
Democrat sweeping 1986 tax law changes
once again under Ronald Reagan and the
welfare reform package of 1996
negotiated between President Bill
Clinton and congressional Republicans
Clinton of course was a Democrat none of
those things in my view would have
occurred in unified government mr.
McConnell's
referring to control of Congress and the
White House by one party the differences
are always big but if you can bridge the
differences then you can survive the
beauty of divided government very few
people say that the beauty of divided
government in the eyes of mr. McConnell
is that it provides both parties with
near bulletproof political cover since
neither can attack the other after
legislation is passed while it also
gives both parties the ability to take
political credit so I'll leave you there
I want you to think about it do you
agree with Senator McConnell that
divided government can actually be a
good thing
or do you think this notion of divided
government and partisanship does lead to
gridlock and for the most part it is a
bad thing and then we could also think
about our system of government because
our system of government definitely
allows for things like a gridlock to
occur while many other systems like a
parliamentary system you always have the
majority or a ruling coalition party
also in charge of the executive so
you're not likely to have this type of
gridlock so think about it which system
do you like and is a divided government
a good or a bad thing